la guerra se está concentrando en la
zona noroeste de kiev el ejército
ucraniano y las tropas rusas están
combatiendo calle por calle en pueblos
como ir ping o lucha también en el este
en jarkiv en su humilde lugansk en el
sur en mariupol en una localidad muy
cercana el ejército ucraniano ha atacado
un buque de la armada rusa de la tropa
del mar negro lo cierto es que el
ejército ruso no ha tomado nuevas
posiciones en los últimos días y esta
invasión se está alargando en el tiempo
hace un mes que escuchábamos el impacto
de los misiles rusos sobre el aeropuerto
militar de costo male muy cerca de kiev
y durante todo este tiempo este país se
está resistiendo militarmente pero ha
cambiado por completo el drama
humanitario está presente en
prácticamente toda la geografía hay
ciudades sitiadas
arrasadas bombardeadas como mariupol
kharkiv hay 7 millones de desplazados
internos 3 millones y medio más de tres
millones y medio de refugiados y las
víctimas de civiles mortales son cerca
de 1000 personas
la vida en esta invasión rusa